about a hundred miles from Washington DC
is one of the most isolated places in
America Virginia's Tangier Island is
home to a crabbing community that's made
its living off the water for more than
200 years but that way of life and the
island itself could be coming to an end
in the new book chesapeake requiem
author earl swift says the island could
be one of our nation's first climate
change casualties
chip Reid has a story on a clear day a
peaceful boat ride to the middle of the
Chesapeake Bay will bring you to Tangier
Island the Adil ik home to about 450
people all facing a dire threat their
Island is slowly disappearing due to sea
level change and shoreline erosion what
inspired you to write a book about this
island well you've got a remote
community that are working theocracy in
many ways that is facing the end times
they're trying to grapple with them off
there earl swift first set foot here as
a reporter nearly two decades ago he
recently returned and spent 14 months
documenting a vanishing community and
way of life this is a place in crisis
and it is merely the first of hundreds
if not thousands of American towns that
will be in similar crisis over the next
20-30 years it's a question as to
whether it's already too late for some
parts of the country if it is changed
here will be the first place to go since
1850 this island has lost two-thirds of
its land mass some marine scientists
believe water levels will rise about two
more feet by the year 2050 Tangier
rarely tops three feet above the tides
is it too late for Tangier no not
without heroic intervention but it would
be it would have to be truly heroic
heroic on the part of the federal
government I don't imagine anyone else
could come up with the money that it
would take to do it the US Army Corps of
Engineers plans to build a three million
dollar jetty that would ease erosion
next year the Corps wants approval by
Congress and the Trump administration
for a large-scale study to examine how
to protect Tangier
Lucian's could be a seawall around the
island breakwaters or relocation of
residents to another part of the island
or the mainland the price tag could be
hundreds of millions of taxpayer dollars
it is so beautiful from right here can
you imagine this ever not existing no no
I can we've been here for hundreds of
years and I want to be here for hundreds
more and I don't even want to visit the
thought that that's we'll all be going
one day James Eskridge known as Bucher
is tangiers mayor he's also one of many
here who make their living off the water
in this soft-shell crab capital of the
world
so these guys are not going to bite me
no no that is a soft crab yep is this
ready for her eating yep
okra admits his island is disappearing
but he blames wave erosion not climate
change
I don't think man has that power to
affect the klahn it like that like they
say in talking with a lot of people it's
amazing to me that if when people hear
about change your disappearing they
automatically think of sea-level rise
they cannot grasp the concept of erosion
can you envision a day or do you try to
not envision a day when people would
have to start evacuating this I don't I
don't think about that I don't I don't
go there I know a lot of folks are
saying you know well water was you just
a move to the mainland and start start
over but you know did I think that's
foolish talk I mean to leave your home
and your business most people here are
strong supporters of President Trump
lucre spoke to the president by phone
last year and says he wants him to build
that wall around the island he said
America first I mean it's just common
sense he's the president of United
States it should be America first under
me I'm the mayor of Tangier all and it
stands here first with me for author
earl swift tens your island is a
harbinger of what's to come this is the
canary in the coal mine
we've got 88,000 miles of shoreline in
the United States and a lot of it is
it's going to be experiencing the
effects of sea-level rise nowhere near
as soon as it's change here is saying it
but yeah this this is coming down the
road for an awful lot of the East Coast
a lot of the Gulf Coast and areas with
much larger populations than this New
York City among them Miami
Norfolk yeah so one of the questions we
have to ask ourselves as a country is
his headcount the only metric you use to
decide whether disabled place we have to
decide what's important to us and that's
that's going to be really ugly it's
gonna be a tough process to go through
for CBS this morning Saturday chip Reid
Tangier Island Virginia